bravo à EOL et rendez-vous en 2026 et
pas si tout va bien voilà pas si tout va
bien rendez-vous en 2026 point final
voilà la présidente de la région île-de-
France plaisante à demi-mot 7 ans après
le début des travaux le rere est plus
qu'attendu l'objectif de ce projet
prolonger la ligne qui part de Paris
saint-lazar jusqu'à monte-laajolie en
passant par poissie vernouiller ou
encore Les Mureaux et pour réaliser ce
projet et accueillir au mieux les 620000
futurs voyageurs quotidiens plusieurs
gares ivelinoises ont été réaménagées
comme Villen sur scène et auberge en
ville sur les différentes gares on fait
des travaux de mise en accessibilité des
bâtiments pour que chacun puisse emprter
le transport on fait aussi des travaux
pour améliorer la capacité desgard
puisque EOL va amener davantage de de
voyageurs et de clients et puis aussi en
travaille en en interface avec le
territoire pour faciliter
l'intermodalité c'est-à-dire la
correspondance entre les différents
modes de transport prévu initialement
pour 2022 puis pour 2024 le RER EOL a
connu plusieurs retards des retards d en
grande partie à la crise sanitaire à des
problèmes techniques ou encore à des
problèmes financiers aujourd'hui les
élus voient le bout du tunnel le projet
EOL est vraiment sans mauvais jeu de mot
sur les bons rails ça avance nos
concitoyens yvelinois et en particulier
dans le nord des ivelines en Vallé de
scè avais le sentiment que c'était des
discours des discours du blabla du
blabla c'est une réalité concrète et
grâce à EOL le confort va être amélioré
pour les transports en commun sur la
ligne entre mante et Paris le projet EOL
c'est enfin un ROR qui arrive sur la
branche ouest d'Île-de-France car la
ligne parimante aujourd'hui n'avait pas
de ROR nous étions la dernière ligne ne
pas avoir de ROR en île-de-fance coût
total du projet 1,6 million d'euros pour
la gare de Villen sursè et 12,15 million
d'euros pour la gare d'auberganville
ellisabethville les travaux ont été
principalement financés par le
Département des Yvelines la région
Île-de-France et l'agglomération Grand
Paris saoise au printemps ce sera le
terminus de la ligne la gare de
montelajolie qui sera inaugurée